this video sponsored by Skillshare stick
around to find out how you can get three
months of Skillshare for just 99 cents
hey wisecrack jared here it may be the
new year but we've still got a massive
hangover from 2017 s final blockbuster
right a film at left us cross-eyed and
confused netflix spent ninety million
dollars combining two of our favorite
things the dystopian fantasy and the
buddy-cop and left us with the world's
most expensive WTF
we've been scratching our heads trying
to figure out how such an awesome
concept think rush hour 2 of the deathly
hallows Nate the weapon up the Rings
ended up feeling as big a show as David
Ayer's last movie sorry I couldn't help
it like other fantasy films it seems to
be using its imaginary setting to tell a
compelling story while also illuminating
truths about our society however both
its plot and any potential underlying
meaning become completely muddled by the
film's poor world-building lousy
character development and ill-suited
metaphors about American racial politics
so let's find out what happened in this
week's wisecrack edition on bright what
went wrong and if you like this sort of
thing there's more where this came from
in our movie podcast show me the meaning
links in the description be sure to
check it out and as always major minor
and vaguely judgmental spoilers ahead
head-scratcher number one building the
world every time you see a film you're
asked to take a leap of faith and accept
some kind of proposition but loving
parents occasionally leave their
youngest child behind when they go on
vacation or that Keanu Reeves is the
most badass assassin ever but when
you're watching a fantasy that plays
with gravity object permanence or the
entertainment potential of a piece of
furniture filmmakers have to convince
you to take a Mount Everest sized leap
off a peak of disbelief and land with
their characters in a distant galaxy
Middle Earth or a faraway distant land
inside a wardrobe a good script gets the
audience to buy into its world by
explaining the rules of that world
coherently and concisely and getting the
heck on with the story
think of how effective Lord the Rings is
in briefing the audience on the history
of middle-earth SMO sought-after jewelry
it began with the forging of the great
rings
three were given to the elves seven to
the dwarflords and nine nine rings were
gifted to the race of men but they were
all of them deceived for another ring
was made a master ring to control all
others one ring to rule
with an origin story clocking in at 6
minutes the film situates us firmly in
this complex world for an even leaner
example consider Star Wars epic rolling
title card that introduces you to an
intergalactic space war in the time it
takes to unwrap a candy bar both films
orient the audience quickly and then
they're off to the races
brights origin story on the other hand
is just plain messy divulged and sloppy
repetitive yet incomplete fragments but
before we analyze the world building
strategies a brief overview of the
mythology behind bright 2,000 years ago
something gnarly went down with a Dark
Lord all your decided with him except
this one orc jurrac who somehow United
the nine races together and who are the
nine races well it's not exactly clear
we've got the elves humans orcs fairies
and for the eagle-eyed viewer centaurs
but anyway they managed to take down the
Dark Lord except bouffes he's ready to
come back and all his demon elves need
to do is bring three wands together
watch out though only a bright can hold
a wand
which creates complications still even
if the dark board does rise he can be
stuffed with magic that whole subplot
never comes to fruition though probably
to be saved for the recently greenlit
sequel that will hopefully come with
some clarification now it's totally
understandable that the minds behind
bright wanted to fear away from the
dramatically narrated story books I'll
opener of Lord of the Rings it's not
exactly the freshest turf in the
screenwriting world or it would be
understandable if Wright hadn't started
out with an equally cheesy but less
eloquent quote that sounds like it came
out of a 10 year olds Dungeons & Dragons
game from there they have an opening
sequence of cringe-worthy tagging you
would think with ninety million dollars
they could afford to hire a decent la
graffiti artist through this we learn
there's interspecies upheaval police
brutality and lizard people roaming the
streets you know it's pretty rude to
tease the existence of lizard people and
not deliver but I digress these shots of
the street explains some atmospheric
aspects of the film's world but we're
still missing the cold hard facts for
instance who is the Dark Lord and what
did he do and why are all the social
media influencers elves we weren't the
only people scratching our heads either
after fans expressed widespread
confusion as to what the heck was going
on with all this Dark Lord stuff Netflix
released what amounted to a 2-minute
instruction manual for the film in it
were given a few thousand years of
magical history with factual nuggets
like Chirac was hailed as the first
bright but if jock saved everyone why do
people hate orc so damn much and how did
this world social order come about this
video feels more like a hastily
concocted admission of guilt that this
film was confusing as hell another world
building issue is the way the film
conveys the limited information it does
tell the audience which brings us to a
fundamental screenwriting rule showing
versus telling showing is when a film
conveys information through characters
actions telling is when characters chat
about the events of the world the
narrative equivalent of an Intel
briefing for the audience and boy is
bright a telethon throughout the film
characters regularly serve as embedded
narrators a strategy that swallows the
action and creates stiff unrealistic
dialogue for instance the award for
worst line in the film goes to Ward's
daughter in this Cringer okay we get it
another prime example comes from Ward
early on Hey look I got a dude in my car
the whole world is watching I didn't ask
for it I don't want it but I don't get a
vote first of all this speech is
stupendously heavy-handed nobody talks
like this secondly these facts can be
shown in a natural way through the
narrative in fact Ward makes it pretty
clear he'd rather be shunned by a fairy
than right to work alongside Jacobi
don't say just try to work
still the winner for the most forced
proxy narrator has to be the smelly
sword-wielding bum who goes from trying
to samurai a crowd of people to calmly
relaying the entire world's backstory
without even a shower break the army of
nine races fight shoulder to shoulder to
give you the world you neglect and now
the dark one returns to reclaim orc
hearts then as the feds interrogate him
he gives a plodding explanation of his
Shield of lights in Fernie wands the
Dark Lord lay Latika and bright this
scene is a boring and B doesn't make
sense unless you assumed federal agents
in charge of magic crime are asked for
confused by the rules of their world as
we are this strategy continues
throughout the film once Jacobean Ward
find the magic wand and call for backup
for skeezy cops show up and give us
another forced lecture on how magic
works that's magic right there that's
whatever you want you want a million
dollars you want ten million I'm gonna
be taller or shorter make it get bigger
you want to go back in time and marry
the girl who didn't blow you on prom
night
that's how you do it right there they
continue to narrate the plot as if the
audience would be absolutely flummoxed
by the concept of dirty cops so what's
the real plan
two cops died tonight it's clearly done
for the audience's sake and it's corny
as hell the script spooned feeds us huge
plot points and small details alike like
when war Jacobi and teeka are fleeing
the Mexican gang and war yells windows
up bulletproof is he patronizing Jacobi
or the audience who even knows just for
fun they remind us needless expositions
CAD sometimes this tiresome exposition
manages to somehow be both forced and
incomplete for instance Jacobi gives a
snooze inducing and scattered
explanation of his workin idle durock he
was a farmer who changed the world okay
and they raised their blades damn she
was blooded okay so Jacque was a former
farmer who was wait what was that blood
okay seriously what is the deal with
this blooding thing he's not part of any
bloody plan he's like a finger that got
cut off the hand he's dead to us
Jacobi who is not blooded explains that
it's a sign of Honor in the orc
community what you did tonight
that's what it takes for an orc to get
blooded an act of great bravery so are
we supposed to think that all these
other orcs are brave except Jacobi the
one who professionally puts his life in
harm's way and what does blooding even
mean Jacobi's sad dental situation as
compared to his brother and suggests
it's definitely tooth related we finally
get a peek at this blooding ritual at
the end of the film after Jacoby saves
fourth and the same orcs who only have
an hour ago killed him
slipped their palms because apparently
clan loyalty means never having to say
you're sorry
hey at least that's showing not telling
so gold star if only we understood what
the heck is going on or how this crowd
of orcs knew that Jacobi had just
committed an act of bravery is there
some kind of work bat signal where they
just following Jacoby all night waiting
to shed blood which would magically give
Jacoby be perfect org smile on the
bright side the next day Jacoby does
appear to be teething on his new fangs
moving on to head scratcher number two
hero smear oh whether you're writing
about outer space
downtown Baltimore or a Wizarding school
in an English castle the first
ingredient of a good story is a hero or
two or three
bright we have Ward and Jacobi and
neither will undergo significant
character development over the course of
the film Ward begins the film as a
snarky [ __ ] well if you in the Box
I'll probably be like and ends the film
as a snarky [ __ ] Thank You Big Dawg
now you bloody Jacobi begins as a
toothless insecure guy who can't stand
up for himself girls can you make a
shootout awkward sorry and ends the film
is a slightly toothed guy who Ward still
treats like a tattooed Forrest Gump
thank the nice federal agents thank you
beyond that for a film centered on an
unlikely friendship their relationship
also seems pretty stagnant at best it
could be said that Ward learns to
tolerate Jacoby and not narc on him
which is pretty bleak as far as buddy
films go it's not surprising they never
change because they never really had
character journeys to begin with a
number one rule in making a compelling
hero
according to Aaron Sorkin is that
somebody's gotta want something
something's got to be standing in the
way of getting it you do that and you
have a scene eventually you'll have a
movie - Wesley wants princess Buttercup
Ferris Bueller wants to cut class and
party and so on and bright not so much
war doesn't appear to actively want
anything except maybe to lose Jacoby as
his partner and keep his job without
being a corrupt [ __ ] that said he
doesn't pursue those goals in any
meaningful way Jacoby does want to be
blooded but that's explained earlier we
don't really understand what the heck
being blood it is or what it means for
him as a character does he have to
submit to clan loyalty to hang out with
those Miami orcs I mean they seemed fun
while a want makes a hero initially
compelling the euros choices are what
makes a character's stay compelling
apparently Dustin Hoffman won't even
sign on to a movie unless his character
has no less than 40 points of choice in
the script rather than 40 points of
choice our main guy's face approximately
40 points of coincidence that saved
their butts such a coincidence is called
a deus ex machina or a person or thing
that appears suddenly and provides a
contrived solution to an apparently
insoluble difficulty most notable among
these is the
wand and one in since the wand saw the
inconvenience of Jacobi dying in another
Ward's totally random status as a bright
turns what would have been an act of
suicide into a semi heroic a hundred
percent coincidental feat now for her
head scratcher number three when a
metaphor is a train wreck
bright is littered with unsubtle
metaphors comparing interspecies
discrimination with real-world racial
discrimination even chance the rapper
called the metaphor a little shallow we
more than a little degree but before we
take a deep dive into the meanings of
play we want to give the following
disclaimer yes this is a fictional world
in which nine races coexist with varying
levels of friction
maybe the filmmakers have no intention
of it being read as a precise metaphor
for American racial politics problem is
the movie practically begs you to draw
this comparison first off it's a film
about cops set in LA a city that was
home to one of the country's most
violent race riots ever won which was
specifically ignited by police violence
toward black folks bright very
deliberately draws comparisons between
orcs and black Americans in ways that
are too obvious to ignore from the
graffiti to the urban street where
visual adaptations of black culture
abound they're marginalized by other
races in society and face victimization
at the hands of the police in truly
sophisticated symbolism the film
suggests the cops would definitely kill
the hooded Org and the troops are coming
chopped up humans with guns looking for
an orchid shot a cop
you think that kid had a chance just for
fun one Orca tells Jacobi your buddy so
happy to say he's got an ork friend not
knowing that Ward very dramatically
doesn't do friends you don't want me as
a friend
oh geez dude save it for your Centaur
therapist that metaphor is referenced
most disturbingly when Jacoby is hung by
a rope during a fight scene with an elf
I don't need to spell out why putting a
character that has been signified as
black in this situation is more than a
little messed up
oh and one very important distinction
between orcs and black Americans orcs
apparently caused their oppression or at
least their great great great great
grand orc daddies did when they decided
to side with the Dark Lord
needless to say real racial prejudice
does not work that way ie black
Americans have zero sins to pay for when
you're making a metaphor about race it's
important to be very very precise
because there's a real danger that an
ill-conceived metaphor can muddle an
already complicated conversation to
understand why let's examine the
cognitive function of metaphors in their
influential book metaphors we live by
scholars George Lakoff and Mark Johnson
explained that metaphors are vital to
human beings understanding of the world
around us that's because metaphors our
way of taking a human's understanding of
a simple often physically tangible
concept and transferring that
understanding onto another for
complicated concept often one hidden
from our senses or difficult to explain
lake often Johnson argue that when we
make a metaphor say comparing madness to
love we're not just momentarily linking
to ideas we're also transferring an
extensive array of our cognitive
associations about what constitutes
madness on to love as a result a human
struggling to write a valentine card can
explain why they have butterflies in
their belly as a result metaphors may
create realities for us especially
social realities leading us to view the
metaphor as being true so in this case
lovers be cray so what does all this
have to do with fictional orgs when a
film like bright unsubtle II evokes a
metaphor that transfers the viewers
understanding of the inhuman orcs onto
black Americans
they inherently invite the possibility
that viewers will transfer all their
cognitive associations about what
conscious
- - orcs a race of homogenous
inarticulate tattooed gangsters on to
that of the extremely complex and most
importantly human group of black
Americans it's not like bright is going
to radically harm race relations but
this practice does place it somewhere in
an ugly history of American cinema
comparing people of color to inhuman
creatures before we go further into this
it's important to address the colorblind
elephant in the room bright depicts a
world where a black man of ward status
can exist seemingly without facing
bigotry or to quote chance the rapper
racism is gone because we hate orc now
that's messed up more so even when you
couple it with Ward's treatment of
marginalized creatures all of which
evoke treatment of black Americans by
police officers whether he's saying
fairy lives don't matter today or
watching a bunch of orcs get beat up
than asking Jacobi I need to know if
you're a cop first or first it just
feels odd in a country where violence
against black men by police officers
remains heartbreakingly common depicting
a black cop this way just feels way way
off the mark
Ward's character seems to be there to
both protect the film against charges of
racism because how can a movie be racist
when it shows a black man as equal and
even getting to be racist himself and
make a backwards argument about how far
black America has come through an
individual representation of a black man
who's made it and earned respect now
back to the specifics of the film's
depiction of orcs which makes it even
more icky while Jacobi is an honorable
guy with a working moral compass his
depiction is not particularly flattering
for starters and there's no easy way to
say this Jacoby is not the sharpest this
is most painfully obvious near the end
of the film which Jacobi cannot stop
spilling incriminating evidence to the
two federal agents the film doesn't make
it better when Ward tells his daughter
all of the races are different while
there's something to be said for
respecting ethnic and cultural
differences Ward's comments seem to
suggest the existence of actual
biological racial differences dwarfs
have mad hops I'm a New York Cevallos
excuse me I heard the detective how many
dogs play pro basketball none they're
slow they're heavy that's why half the
NFL
the blinds of orcish it's not racism to
physics and yes they're fictional
characters who are literally of
different species but the metaphor still
evokes black Americans and it feels
plain weird
that coupled with Jacobi's clear
inability to match Ward's intellect
which falls into the trap of a voguing
hundreds of years of junk racist biology
that tried to excuse racism on the
grounds that people of color were
intellectually inferior at the same time
giving orcs a super strong sense of
smell gives them an animalistic quality
that again makes the metaphor super ugly
particularly when you consider the
hundreds of years of white Americans
treating black Americans like sub human
beings as like often Johnson explained
what is at issue is not the truth or
falsity of a metaphor but the
perceptions and inferences that follow
from it and the actions that are
sanctioned by it metaphors like the one
in bright in comparing people of color
to in human beings are [ __ ] up even if
they had good intentions and as like
often johnson explained we define our
reality in terms of metaphors and then
proceed to act though it makes some
superficial points about tolerance and
encourages the audience to empathize
with Jacobi's experience of
marginalization abusive friendships and
kick me signs brights overarching
metaphor is just plain sloppy brights
led us down but given our world of
inevitable sequels prequels three cools
and squeak walls we suspect elves and
orcs will be duking it out on your
favorite streaming platform for years to
come and we're not mad at it Netflix has
a cool concept to work with and in case
you haven't heard a disgusting amount of
dough to throw at it so here's the
hoping the sequel gives us something
special thanks for watching everybody
peace thanks for watching wise practice
with the new year upon us there's never
been a better time to set some
resolutions and pick up some new skills
so head on over to skill share shoot get
started skill share is an online
learning community where for less than
$10 a month you can access expert-led
courses in just about any field you can
think of want to learn these basic
screenwriting techniques that might have
saved Will Smith's character art or pick
up the design principles that may have
given the orcs a bit more of an
interesting look skill shares got you
covered with more than 18,000 courses
and everything from writing to
photography business entrepreneurship
and
and for the end of January you can get
your first 3 months of Skillshare for
$0.99 just follow the link in the
description to SK l dot s H slash
wisecrack 99 and get your discounts
today don't be shy let us know about all
the cool things you learn and as always
be sure to subscribe and ring that bell
she won't miss what we've got coming
next
we've got episodes on American Psycho
Captain America Civil War and tons more
on the way you won't want to miss it as
always catch all the next time peace
[Music]